This is a 100-acre wood game.
Yeah!
Oh, not you again.
Piglets.
Boink.
Ah.
What is that thing?
Uh.
Duh.
Is it supposed to be a claw?
Because it's got, like, marshmallows on the end.
Uh.
Okay, that was just weird.
I'll poison you.
Hey, that doesn't affect me, because I've got my love shield on.
Heya.
You didn't affect me at all.
Eternal Grounding!
Well, we have a plan to defeat you this time.
We are going to use the Rahkshi's Krata to infect you from the inside of your shield.
But the Krata, or whatever they are, can't even get inside it.
And perhaps Bohrok will be able to drain your energy.
Breach.
Uh.
He's draining my energy, but...
Ugh.
Uh.
But he's not knocking me out.
That I could drain the energy from him for forever, and I'd still not get rid of him.
Yes.
He holds eternal power.
Duh.
That didn't affect me at all.
Ah.
Can't get my arm back on.
Ugh.
Substitute.
You've gotten smaller.
Yup.
That's what I do.
Body slam.
Infect the ground.
Ugh.
Holy rock.
Now I'll drain its energy.
Release the Krata.
Huh?
Slug thing.
Ugh.
You can't affect me that easily.
Not if you've only got one.
How about three?
Huh?
Especially this one.
Pure power, you know.
The Krata.
Get it off of me.
Draining my shield energy.
I'll splat.
Splatter.
Grr.
Krata.
Get him.
Ugh.
Get off.
Stomp.
I got you.
You cannot resist my energy.
Hey.
That's a good way to stay on.
Huh?
Duh.
Substitution.
Wee.
It's Tigger.
Super duper.
Loopy loop.
Alley looper.
Bounce.
Leerock.
Ground him.
Tiggers cannot be defeated by evil Rahkshi.
Wee.
Tee.
No, Leerock.
You cannot loose.
Not be defeated by some children's story book creature.
Well, not exactly.
Tee.
Yeeahh.
Wee.
Armbar plating is being destroyed thanks to that stupid tail whip.
I'll pick up this mask you can't throw a mask yes I can
mega yeah this is mega flop come here Lyra get him with the sleep ray it
doesn't affect me this time hey yeah no use um what do you call it uh oh shut up
you know you know noses on them hypnosis my most attack most powerful
attack I give this power to baby Sam worry don't mention that word around me
again I'm super duper it's crushing cocoa
hit me with that all the time that motorbike I love it I gotta clip it to
you I don't have to well I say y'all I
slug
you're gonna say here here what I have a pretty little use your cocoa attack
when you're back I have a pretty little flower cocoa attack is a cocoa attack
okay give you have to give me some cocoa you I'm gonna get myself some cocoa it's
a good healing it's a good attack and a good healing because it tastes so good
that helps you and it's hot too
hey cool I want like that and I'm not gonna get you me hey yeah if it doesn't
for you because these are different types of masks dude these are special
kind of masks they like go back right on go right on they can't cuz I'm cutting
them on to my slipper thing see I'm a tiger rawr see I cooked it on so he gets
good spot haha it's a pretty cool
jewelry thing do you have a
oh cool
oh ballast
let me line your heart
remains you have you have back up
don't tell me that's for deep or is that I don't know nothing that goes like
it goes in please
no I can't find the pull much I'm funny i got on top right there quite fast
I didn't find my nut yet.
Makita's my nut.
Oh, shut up.
Now you need to find your screw.
Bolt.
Gotcha.
Hi-ya, hi-ya, hi-ya, hi-ya, hi-ya.
I can't find that little nut.
Hey, cool.
I have funny tail, you can't do it.
You don't have a funny tail, you can't do it.
They burn.
Splash.
Ugh, now drink some.
Leaves a good after taste in my mouth.
Razor blaze.
Ching ching.
Get you ching ching.
Hi-ya, cha.
Why do you, instead of let go,
why do you always say lego?
I don't get it.
Cha.
Hi-ya, ya, ya, ya.
I shall drain all your energy.
I have failed.
Now I shall use my attack.
No spin.
It's Agent 9 and Sheila.
There we go.
Yep.
Boom, bash, bash.
Tail whip.
Hey, that was pretty cool.
Ching ching ching.
I'm gonna get that kangaroo.
What are you sniffing for?
Monkey beam.
Who you always say that make thing?
Make, make, make, make, make.
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
That's what they always, that's what you always say.
Mike beam.
Make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make, make.
Mike.
Face to the side and I fell over.
What are you sniffing for?
Man.
I am the monkey.
Take this mask in my pouch.
Yah, yah, yah, yah, yah, yah, yah, yah.
Agent 9, go.
Kai, attack.
Ha, I've got the worst teeth.
What do you mean worst?
I'll save you.
I didn't mean Kai.
Ear, pierced ear.
Why are you confusing me?
You look like an elf or something.
Ear, ear, ear.
Punching kick.
It's Dan and Song.
Oh, for a second there, I thought you were my worst nightmare.
You mean our children?
Yes.
I'm proud of that.
Your son and daughter are my worst nightmares.
Well, actually your sons.
And not my little baby?
Get off.
Whoa, that was cool.
Cool.
You see that one?
It hit me in the face.
It hit me in the face that time.
Ooh.
That was cool.
Can you get me the mask up, Lou?
Sure.
I'm just going to put these back on.
I'm not going for the heck of it.
Plus, it takes health away.
It doesn't take health away when I put them on, just when I knock them off.
This is fun.
Hang on.
Dang it.
You got to like hold yourself by the legs and then go like flop on it.
Hold myself by the leg?
That's weird.
Hang on.
Try that.
Eh?
Probably because he's more bouncy.
Ah!
He caught me on a spikes.
Slash, slash.
My hip.
More towards me part.
He's looking at me.
Well, the kid has got all the mean ones.
But if we collect them, we can turn them nice.
Okay.
And then turn them to heel masks.
Ha!
In fact, those are the ones that infected that mask that you see in front of you.
Oh, dang it.
I can't hit it.
Let's go with my tail.
It'll be nice.
Good luck.
Stop rolling on me.
Dang, it's not working.
I feel a draft.
Well, kind of.
If you're in a cold room, then a hot room would be a draft if you left the door open.
Okay!
Okay.
There we go.
Now I've got to tickle it.
Ha!
You can't.
That's my signature Krata.
What?
Once I put my Krata in, I am more powerful than ever.
Krata!
I took all your colors out.
What?
Color!
They're coloring it.
It looks like...
I mean, it looks like it's colored in crayon.
Oh, shut up.
Fool.
Ha!
Now you're all blurry.
That's not gonna work.
It does.
Baby, just why aren't you wearing your ribbon?
I am.
Oh.
Fool.
I'm gonna turn you really old!
Oh boy.
They're good, they're fighting.
Ah, stop it.
Uh-oh.
Ah, super night shot.
I, I, ah, never mind.
Will you stop?
Oh, I bet.
Chika raka, chika raka, chika boom.
I said a boom, chika raka, chika raka, chika boom.
Ah, Roxy.
All of you, get in there.
The Drainer, the Shatterer, the...
Descender Waiter.
I said Descender Waiter.
Descender Greater.
Dictionary.
I know.
Leerock.
Turok.
Back them.
Next round.
Next two.
Get them, Turok and Turok.
You can beat them.
Turok, give them a heart attack.
Whoa.
Get in there.
Cha, cha.
I need to sharpen my needles.
You know what to do.
They'll be so angry at each other
that this will be my foot.
I win it.
Now make them angry.
Make them scared of me, but angry at themselves.
They can't lose.
Well, they can.
They will not lose.
Well, they will lose.
Why do I keep saying that they won't?
Shoot them with a gun.
Mega laser.
Just a second.
She won't use her last attack, you sample.
Big attack, I can't, for some reason.
Cool.
I'm defending at all angles.
Ah, wait.
I'll pass it at the same time.
Cool.
In the song battle, Dan was like, whew.
And it went, I'll get you.
Are you?
And you're not much of a house cleaner.
I can turn things into dust.
Exactly.
Time to break out the Swiffers.
Bang smack.
Here's your mommy, here's your mommy, here's your mommy.
Man.
This game's off.
Go, man, go.
Then who is?
Because Makuta's your dad.
Get Reacher.
Whack, you're whacked.
Get her.
Ear punch.
Yeah, yeah.
Whoops, I meant to hit him.
Dang, I missed.
Super mega flying fire.
Anti-bomb.
Theresa, Theresa and Scorch.
My tail.
Guess what?
Pon Rock just, just graduated from medical school.
I am a specialist in shot and needles for shots.
I'll give you a shot.
Pon Rock, get her, Pon Rock.
Remember, your shots can make things explode.
Oh no.
You're supposed to attack there.
I attack.
You wouldn't have to go through this if you didn't want to conquer the world so much.
It was you that wanted to battle this time.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
We are the Toad Noob and did you know that, Makuta?
No, I thought they were different people.
Well, that's what Layla said the first time they came, they came, they, you saw them.
My mask.
We're going to get suited up.
Wait a second.
Prepare yourself, Makuta.
We're ready.
And don't forget.
Don't forget.
Here comes the box or vehicle.
It can act on its own too.
Noogie.
All right, somebody's going to get in it.
I'm going to get you.
This is a, there we go.
There we go.
Two more times.
Punch it.
Hey, what you doing?
Mega punch.
More like mega claw.
Of course it is, you bing cherry.
That means that I'm sour.
Re-jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab.
Explosion.
No, I've knocked my mask off.
You fool.
You've been leaping.
You make these attacks sound so stupid, but they're really just power, power, flash.
I wish I had Yoda here.
I'm going to have to sing a song.
Ah, shut up.
I'm going to knock my mask off.
Crunch.
There we go.
That's going a lot better.
Watch out.
Yep.
The box or vehicle has been acting really weird lately.
That was weird.
Now, where was I?
Prepare to meet Mr. Fist.
Mr. Fist?
Who's Mr. Fist?
Which is also the updated form of Leaf.
I have failed.
The box so here I go.
Here comes the.
Oh yeah, right.
He already said that.
That's not funny.
This is funny.
Pine cone.
Is this something a pine cone to you?
It isn't to me.
Because he just said it looks like a pine cone because I don't like my staff to be called
a pine cone.
Hey, I knocked that off.
Hey, give it back.
I have to hack it you.
I'm going to use spit attack.
What do you mean spit?
I mean the mask was on my stick like a spit.
Which you'd get.
gross things and um it was fit because i wanted to get on dad get new ones if you don't keep
battling with them this will be the last time we ever battle with them that was weird i have
to chuck this at you no shield you're holding it's a chrono shield oh i don't believe it can
block chrono chrono go and especially because this is a chrono cop block kick
i learned um i lured him into giving all his power to me and then um i killed him you're mean
hey let's go slash slash slash slash i'm pretty good at this you're slash slash
charlie has got less mask time than the chahunga do it's matoran now slash slash slash yeah but
you only have one more mask light thing
i do uh you're gonna feel like me slash slash slash
i told you we're not weaklings but we'll show you the true power of
imtoa soon hey yup dummy doesn't you're weird makuta that wasn't even attack i'm gonna get ya
it's not it's not cool you're spinning all over me take now i'm gonna use because i can't get in oh
you get the exotone that was like that i'll take it
what i'll take oh shut up
ding derg i'm talking dutch
the plentyong i guess
foreign language
talk you out
no i mean you're not gonna steal this mask
hey this is actually my mask
ha they don't even know how to change masks
oh don't we
this
is the kanohi mask of uh
it's the noble mask of concealment
i'll go invisible
it's an infected
ähr pegar
this is not an infected mask
it's an infected mask
It should have knocked you out.
It can't.
Because I'm a platform toe.
I'm going to take you down.
I can't take you down because you're too heavy.
On potato chips.
Ha!
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash.
Music.
Music, please.
That's a video game.
I'm going to totally rock your world, Bakuda.
Kick.
I got three more mask lives.
Oh, shut up.
Music start.
I have failed.
Too soon.
No, it's strange.
Well, I guess it's up to me.
Yes.
But I'd actually like you to come with me.
That's cool.
That is, if you want to stay alive.
Next up, Towa.
I am Laywa.
I am Platinum Laywa Nuva.
Laywa.
Cha, cha, cha, cha, cha, cha.
Ho, ya, ho, ya, ho, ya, cha.
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash.
Laywa.
Now you have it.
Oh, yeah.
I like to slash things with my sharp edge.
Nuparu, get them.
And it rang as soon as I started.
This is your first time poking me in the face.
I'm a puncher.
You can hack on to his nose leg.
The original poker.
That's what you called your staff, the poker.
I know how I did that.
You can kind of lose this.
Yarr.
Mask, mask.
The bottom.
The mask.
Makuda.
Gather now.
Okay.
Get it on.
Poka and Pohatu.
Ha.
Your little ones were easily defeated by me.
Oh, is that what you think, Makuda?
We are Toa Platinum.
That means we have platinum mask.
Mask.
Now, we are going to whoop your butt.
You're just taking a while.
Let's kick the good things.
Yeah, let's kick.
That's Makuda's face.
Poka's rear end is Makuda's face.
Kick, kick, kick, kick.
We did that too much.
Kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick
Kick kick kick kick kick
Ugh!
I'm gonna take him down!
I released my last life to take you down, Hakuna
Take down!
Taco up a comma no comma need you
Hurt your mask
Hey, let's barbecue it!
You can?
But it's being barbecued!
Barbecuing a mask
Hey, we scared Turok
Turok's the master of fear
You're a good guy, you know
Listen to my squeakiness
I'm gonna respond
Taco now!
This mask won't come off cause I'm special
What do you mean special?
No Matoran or special
What's the difference?
A water beam on the fire and a fire beam on the water
Me too, I'll say that
He called for his mommy
I'm gonna beat you on the head, Kaddock
The chrono won't work on Vakama this time since he has a little shield
Yup
Oh no!
You have two lives on it though
Yup, so I can
So...
Do something
So you can do something with it
Yeah, that was good cake
It was big cake too
That was good cake
I'm gonna turn this
Cause he killed Nokama before, but now she's back
It's my job
To bump it around part of the arm
I don't know how you do that
Stop that
I almost said nap
What's this?
You gotta stop them from behind
You gotta put your hand down
Oh, I forgot to say my annual saying
The eternal fire is that
You're weird, Makuta
Hey, I can slash them with my eyes
Slash, slash, slash
I'm down
Your boyfriend is too
Your leg and your mask came off this time
Not just your butt, but your leg
That is objectionable
Big head mask?
No
Try this one again
No!
It's just another mask, it's just another mask
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash, slash
Eh?
Actually, he just revived
I'm gonna throw my staff down
Stop it, Makuta
Choo!
Good thing you didn't throw your hand at him
That would be more objectionable
Kanoe Komau, the mask of mind control
Now shut up!
The Kanoe Bond, the mask of time
Makita got knocked out
Real slow because I used the box
I will get you, stupid Niji
Ugh
Finally meet again
Has it been nice?
Have you been training?
Not wimps like last time
But this time, Makuta, we have platinum masks
Very shiny
Now, we are going to, well, defeat you
That kind of stuff
And we will show you the power of the Super Family
So, just be watching out
Oh well, let's just battle already
Show me what you got
From the side of my ear
Facts on Nui Jago
Two of his howls
Knock his cow cow off
My miru will give me strength
No, it won't
Nui Jago, get him
Ah, my mask
My mask
Up until she has one more
That's off by me
I don't know how to use plurals
I have my Akaku
This is the mask of speed
Mine's the mask of X-ray beam
I was saving it because it looks so
Let's just get it
I failed
Howling Galley
It's the Matoran Kaitas
It kind of looks like I got four feet
We got big feet
Bring it on
Yeah
Kick
Boom
You punch really good
It's called whirlwind punch
I need to change something with my feet
Clap
So I can punch better
Ugh
Because I was made out of Nuparu
And Nuparu can't punch very fast
I'm going to rebuild my legs
Shake
Clap
I'm knocked out
I have less lives
Because I'm more powerful
But you are more defensive
Yep
My tail
You can revive your mask for the last turn
Evasion attack
Because I don't know how to
Punching
You like to punch?
I'll get you out
Punch
And then I
No
Literally it failed
It's the Turaga Nui
Yeah
That's right
I only have a short time to battle
Why?
I don't know
I got a busy schedule
But you're a legendary being
That is true
I have the Bahia
That means
My head is still attached
So it'll be
I'm going to get you
Seven masks
And if you can get them all off
Then I guess you win
I'll do it
Freeze beam
I forgot the Bahia is still in effect
Easy
Oh it's your cry thing
Do you need to know?
I went to a spirit
I only have
Water
And don't really need to know that
Well maybe you want to
So you can prepare
Slash you
I'm going to get you
Are you doing it?
Catch, catch, catch, catch, catch
Catch it now
Catching onto things like this
I went to a spirit
I only have three more masks
And not much time
What are you talking about?
You have the Bahia
You have plenty of time
Is this annoying?
Ha
You
That Turaga Nui
Is very, very easy to do
Is that what you think?
Makuta
I only have two more lives
Time
And fire
I'm going to get you
Fire is going to be hard to get
And so is time
Because the time mask doesn't cover his whole face
Well
Goodbye
Because um
Well just goodbye
Oh wait a second
I gotta take a rest
But
What was that big black flash?
I don't know
It's none of my business
Well you're probably the one who caused it
Fool
Like an old guy
Creature
One more step
And I'll
Do what?
Draw on me?
Three
Two
One
What?
I thought that was your most powerful attack
It isn't
Yeah
I froze you before
Oh
She gets it
I'll drain the fear out of him
He won't be scared of Vorok
Okay
Makuta
You didn't drain all my energy
But you drained all my fire energy
Huh
This one is feisty
Makuta
You talk like an old guy
Oh
Shut up
I only have my time power left
But
The time
The mask of time
Never comes off
No matter what you do
Even though it doesn't have that special peg
For the mask
Like the mask of light does
Mask of light?
Yeah
And the Kanoe Trocken
Which I'm sure you have
How am I supposed to know about that?
Well apparently I did because
You're
Responding to me in a negative way
But it seems like you do have it
Oh shut up
Mask of time
Give me power
I should have caught him by then
You did it so fast
Hey this is pretty
Kanoe Bahi
My whole face
Got great defense
Stop telling about
Me about it
Or I'll have to steal it
Steal it
Vorok
Kanoe Bahi never gets knocked out
To wear a Hira and a Kama
The two Trocken
Dan dan dan
Dan
You want a piece of me?
You don't wanna
My feet don't flop like last time
You fools are so
Yeah yeah yeah
With
The
Too tall!
Send him ahead.
That's not good for your health.
Turok!
Get her!
You are the master of fear.
I'm not scared.
Ha ha!
I don't have a head.
So I can't be scared.
Ha ha!
Dang!
My mask finally came off.
So it doesn't affect me.
So I don't have a head on.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
You are delusional.
And that's a good thing.
We're in Europe.
You can't reach yourself.
Get two of our masks.
Take them away.
Knock them out.
The sword?
Hey, you're so stupid.
Now be a good little boy and keep that sword in your head.
I'll just wear this cow.
I need my sword.
I shall keep that.
Tigger?
Why'd you call him Tigger?
Who?
Nevermind.
Did Tigger pass?
I'll take it.
Attack him.
The heck out of him.
Hit.
Noggin.
I thought it was Hunk Noggin.
What?
Slash.
Fairy Cubs.
It's time for us to share.
You can get the speed.
You have you on your feet.
You can get a club.
A club?
A club.
A comedian.
And I need a clubber.
You can club them in your free time.
You can club them when you're hot.
You can club them when you're angry.
You can club them when you're not.
Your heart's lined right up.
Put it there.
So go right ahead and make you mark on your care bears.
Big ol heart.
Scary Cubs.
I will be sure.
You can get those feelings when you club a club.
A club!
Be aenebear!
You can ram and smack and smack and smack your Care Bear all night long
Or you can let them out to dry on the front lawn
Scary cubs, eerie cubs, bedtime cubs to share You can get those feelings when you come out
to share
Don't look now, but it's a free for all
Cubs, beat em or smash em, it's your call
Well set em on the ground, light em ablaze or keep clubbing all your days
Scary cubs, eerie cubs, bedtime cubs to share You can get those feelings when you come out
to share
Don't look now, but it's a free for all
Care Bear
Down to a close Remember this as you wiggle your toes
Love your bear with a heavy go
Cast away
I'm gonna change my eye color
I've changed my eye color
Not that one!
well here's some cheese for you well no if you blast me you'll be a big cuz I'm
gonna use the mask of cheese on you or my tic-tac knock that out use two hands
together
sweet cook suite you chilling片 rind hot dog pepsi to chugging down
doughnuts until yes Pew that guy can't move me in the main street cuz they run
up Bryans the saying brakes just like you when you walk on the floor and the
year
in the year
Your plate measures at 10.4 You're a fat guy, can you get it?
Your mommy tells you to do it And your scale gets stuck at 2 million point
eight You're a fat guy, can you eat it?
You're a fat guy, you try to play with the kids
Hey!
But all they saw was a solar eclipse Your IQ test came out negative
But all that meant was you're not a dick You're a fat guy who can read while you lay
on your side E-Guide, play video games till you break
your hands You got a negative point one Q time and you
eat it Now remember this, you lazy mo
The next time you eat a sloppy joe From head to toe
Geez, this fat guy thing is going to go down the drain
Hamer said, I am a fat guy I have failed
It's the Toa Nuva But this time, I have somebody to counteract
your What was that?
The rock sheet, made by little pieces of you
Ericantilus, don't let go on No, I'm just going to use one for now
I'll put my mask over there for now Oh no, not him, he's the one who kicked the
rock and knocked off the mask last time It may not be a mask, that's what I told you
last time
This is my cannoli, uh, my platinum Q You have no idea how powerful
That's what you said last time, Makuta, we still beat you
I'm going to put my normal mask on As you have, I only need my mirror and then
I'll have all my cannoli nuva Here, little bugger
Bad little boy With that little nut thing
Okay, this will go over Hey, that was easy
Aren't you going to get a mask on I'm going to go kick things
You're a cheater, Makuta You keep coming back
Even though we keep saying we destroyed you But that's just nearer to the plan this time
Makuta, Makuta, you're so stupid You could never lure me into telling you the plan
Procter and昨
Procter, get in
Just to like you Like me like me
Procter too evil to be liked They like me
Take them Procter, get in
Heh, you tickle
You'll stay in my back You're supposed to be friendly
You should kick
There isn't too many masks That way, you can go take a break since you're
not...
Hey cool I'm ready to crawl the heck out of you
Crawl the heck out of me?
Yeah! I guess that's the only thing you can do.
I saw a head slot.
Attack!
Heal!
The one there.
Fakunuba.
X-ray visioner.
Multiple visioner.
What did he call it last time?
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash.
Makuta gets one katana while resting.
And how about two?
Two?
Two katanas on the same hand?
Not meant for double blades.
And they look funky.
No they don't.
Or Sarkania.
No, durable.
He's like a negative negative.
So he's not a negative.
Yum yum.
What do you mean yum yum?
Oh shut up.
You don't need to know everything.
That's what I do.
If I'm going to win this battle, then I must have supreme knowledge.
Too bad.
Take off armor thing.
And sword thing.
And other thing.
Very, very, very, very weird.
I'm an, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm
a, I'm evil.
I am, am, I said I am claim evil.
You are not evil.
I said eme evil.
It's a我EME.
I am, am, am, I am, am, I am, I am.
Cal CAW, the mask of water breathing.
In this one game I happen to have, they call it the mask of great distance.
I don't get that.
Because if it's the mask of great distance, what the heck is the use for the Kanoe Kekama.
That makes no sense whatsoever .
Crown, crown, crown.
At least one for the other side.
this stupid thing last time that didn't affect me hey cool i caught him on the end of my leg
my feet can hook on to anything once your head goes up whenever i attack them like a really
shiny toe because the first half of me is all like sober your kick kick kick mega sonic foot
that's cool i'm acting like a baby i'm not a baby makuta i'll show you a baby okay okay i get it
i fail go kaka nuva and i knew a new one yeah she didn't battle too good by herself last time
yeah it does ah how come you're considered about time okay you're weird i'm gonna activate my
rocket breaker it's been a while since i did this you should have said stop copying but i didn't
catching me so when you're done you can get it i just made a big hole in the ground hey stop
not that sport by make sure the one that you swing is out a little farther so you gotta be
so you gotta be
You gotta be looking like, you gotta look like a bat.
Learn things.
I said you're our weirdo.
What happened to your ice face?
One, two, three.
It's at the Kanoe Akaku.
No, not the Akaku, I mean the Pocari.
Yeah.
One more mess.
Take one of his masks off.
It's not a nose.
I didn't even feel anything.
Funny at all.
I think you're a bat guy.
No.
Free time, you can club them when you're hot,
you can club them when you're angry,
you can club them when you're hot.
There's so many ways to club your bear,
so wind her it up and put her in there so go right ahead
and make your mark on your Care Bears, they go hard.
Scary clubs, eerie clubs, bad time, love to share.
You can get those feelings when you come up, come up, club.
You can now use two hands together,
get them on, cook, swipe.
You can rip, stack and smack and smack your Care Bear.
Now as we bring our song to a close,
remember this as you wiggle your toes.
And annihilate her splattin' powerful fun.
Close to there, you can get those feelings
when you come up, come up, club.
Care Bear, that's your most powerful attack.
Word.
Star Who, a dolly.
Say my name funny thing.
You're not cool, but I said I was cool.
Get the boom box ready.
You're not cool, you're.
Keep talking.
Your mask has this little peg in it,
so it'll never come off.
Huh.
Oh.
Don't mention the name.
Even though it does, you don't throw up big.
And that's why I try to hurt you.
Okay, come on, get him.
Sh, sh, sh.
Can't even help my arm hurt.
You don't have any muscles without your chest plate.
I mean, you're.
Why don't you fight?
Because you can't just stand there all day.
Oh, sh, sh, sh.
Now I'm ready to fight.
Stand there and tell me to get my shoes.
I don't even have my mask on.
Yeah.
Something's coming, that I don't like at all.
Weird.
You know the definition of weird?
Yes, you are.
Why don't you do some hand to hand combat instead of,
putting those on your feet all the time?
Feet on feet.
Actually, I need to stop attending now.
It's because I don't have the music on that much.
Sh, sh, sh.
I knocked his thing.
He evolved it, because whenever we get knocked out as Tell,
we transform into the Toa Nuva.
And then we get knocked out as Toa Nuva,
we transform back into Tell.
And I can use it, cause it's just.
You already used your waterfall attack.
Doesn't that take a lot of energy?
How do we do it once in a battle?
It's like this attack that I do,
that you can only do once in a battle.
Let's hit a battle.
Fire Suva.
I can only do that once.
You can only do a Suva attack once.
You can do your Suva attack now.
It like shoots up in the air,
and then it comes down on everything.
Well, my Suva attack, it's different.
It gives me the power to do my tidal wave attack,
and the others, like yours, except for the waterfall.
Yeah, and you already used your Suva power.
And my Suva helps me have more power than yours.
Did that hurt your tongue,
that you were sticking your feet in your mouth,
in your mouth?
Thanks for preoccupying him.
Hey, that was cool.
I just like, I needed like,
his face like melted because of her breath.
Gally, what happened?
Mine too.
You can put it back on.
Just to save Nokama.
It looks very good on you.
Why, thank you.
Because it's the last thing you're ever gonna see,
Makuta.
Huh?
Jam.
Louie Herman's the guy who does SpongeBob sports.
You're somebody who has a pet named Herman.
Yep.
You get me?
No, we talk really fast because time's slowing down.
But guess what, Makuta?
I am one.
Makuta, guess what?
Gally, put your mask on because it's already knocked out.
But Makuta, guess what?
We can battle for one more minute without our mask.
Are you my conscience?
And
Yeah, and sing those funky songs like
You're a fat guy, I can't.
I don't care about the club.
Makuta, it's gonna be quite a show
when Dr. Senor takes the floor.
You look like a fat guy, but you're singing to use.
I guess I can use these.
Oh no.
Yeah, tall enough.
Yeah, and that would probably
You could, but I need a special equipment.
No, I need a bunch of gears.
Yeah.
That's how you can paddle faster.
Paula coming next, Makuta.
Rock sheet, two rock, two rock.
Get your hand out of my face.
Hand on his head and push down.
Okay, okay.
Hey, what you doing?
Am I too toad?
No, I'm gonna do this.
Me in my normal mode.
Hey, can you, you can still do that with your hook.
Yeah, but not as good.
Really?
Yeah, cause you need to like,
put your hand under their mouth, which isn't very,
but it's fun once you get to do it.
That's cool.
As long as you said the United States of America.
Okay.
Round of attack.
High five, Dr. Senor.
Doesn't this orange thing look awesome with me?
Totally.
Hey, what you got?
Orange is so totally my color.
Yeah, like the Vahis like that.
Hey, I got it off his nose.
Oh.
But green wouldn't be your color.
Yellow would be mine.
Okay.
Armor.
My ears back on.
No, they're orange.
They're extinct.
We already do it to her too.
She's organic.
You're made from scrap parts.
Scrappy.
Let's go with scrappy.
Okay.
Scrappy.
Yeah, he did try that, but I didn't do it.
Actually, that was more than one minute together.
Hey dude, can I like get my chunky toe cap?
I have failed.
You have failed.
The bone rock top.
Kazone.
All right, I need to be careful with my Karna
since I only have one.
I have to awaken this.
Well, yeah, because we're on the super family side.
Cool.
You must obey us now, because we awakened you.
You are in here right now, so you have to thank us.
Kazone, do not fall under their energy.
We were born after them.
We are much more powerful than them.
Explosions cannot harness plasma's energy.
You ready for a fight?
You did it.
I love when you say that.
It's not like there's a rock in your throat when you do that.
Hey, cool.
Get it?
Got it?
Good.
I think.
You're supposed to do that.
Why?
Making them come out.
You can actually make them stay in.
This is cool.
It kills me in two.
Now, because we're Baraka.
We can bite and pull, because there's this little gap under her.
Grab one of those.
Don't take my eye.
Kick.
You didn't kick him in the liver.
You didn't kick him in the spleen.
You kicked him in the butt.
Why don't we use our elemental powers and show them off?
We're a big show off.
I don't want to be ahead.
I'm a show off guy.
I'm a good for you.
So think of it that way.
Like the Baraka.
We're like the Toa and the Toa Nuva, except we evolved from the Baraka.
Reverse cycle.
Can I say it?
I don't know if you can say it, even though.
I'm thinking, because your ears already flew off.
So.
Use your sonic energy.
They'll become blind in their ears.
When you get close to me, I start to vibrate.
Now, do this with your hands, and then go like, it activates a boom box, because you're
pretty much the.
Baraka of sound.
Did you know if you make them vibrate enough, they'll shatter?
Cool.
Hey, that's my power, you fool.
Oh, well, maybe I can fly.
Those are too powerful.
I never heard of it.
Did you see that?
Gotcha.
And for that, I'm going to take your claw.
My shot.
There's something wrong with my.
Sticking both of my toes in.
I mean, both of his toes in my hip.
The bone or something.
I can't touch my toe.
My nose.
Look, I can't touch my toe.
I can't touch my toe.
They didn't say you had to touch it with your hand.
Wait.
I can finally touch my toe, because I took my leg off.
Baraka of crying babies, or is she crying by herself?
We're the Baraka of crying babies, because we can drive them crazy.
That wouldn't be very good at home.
You are 16.
I can drive people crazy?
Yeah.
I hate the Baraka.
Yeah, too bad.
Yeah.
Okay, you're just freaking me out.
Okay.
Why don't we use our elemental powers?
We have to.
Plasma.
We can make up, like, different fire.
Hey, that's cool.
It looks like it feels good.
Let me try that.
I can't do it.
Sober.
Really shiny heads.
Want to rub shiny heads?
I want to try shiny heads.
Hey, let's do our shiny attack.
You're going to rub heads, and then you go shiny, and then static flies everywhere.
Zap me.
And then she zapped him.
And then, do me wrong.
This is my butt.
Then you like butts.
I like butts.
Hey, that's cool.
Let me write it down in my notepad.
Guess what?
Stacy uses bug spray.
Oh, no.
Not her.
And it sprays out of her shit.
The most annoying teenager in the Super Family is Stacy.
But the most annoying baby is Baby Sam.
That's not in the Super Family.
It's Pat.
Dumb.
Annoying and dumb are two different things.
You're annoying if you're annoying.
You're dumb.
Well, usually.
That's right.
That is just weird.
I'm smart.
Weird, yes.
Smart, but.
I like being Barack Obama, because they're cool.
What did you do to your legs?
It's like, you got the football.
And like, I have the football here.
This will be the football.
This mask will be the football.
No, just watch.
This will be fun.
Get out of here.
Take your stuff with you.
Okay.
I'm packing up and leaving, Dad.
See you later.
Bye.
Don't forget.
Special.
Around here.
Where?
The local.
Jakes, you owe me a soda.
Well, you didn't say that with your own money, so.
Jakes, you owe me a soda with your own money.
Are you okay?
Take your spirit, Mwaka.
This time.
Ugh, I have failed.
My last two on him.
Sound content increasing.
Warning.
Yep.
We have failed.
What?
But there are more Bohrok-Kal to come.
Gale, vacuum power, Makuta,
the first let's get our car in.
Ha!
Hate these Bohrok-Kal already.
Well, you're really gonna hate Galak-Kal and Nubok-Kal.
I mean, Galak-Kal and Tanak-Kal.
What the heck is wrong with me?
Snapping back fast enough.
What the heck is wrong?
What's wrong with Nubok-Kal?
His neck is not snapping back fast enough.
Duh, could it be this?
Hey, I fixed it.
Avadi sure is powerful.
Yep, but it is funny too.
Cool.
He's a fighter, but he's really powerful.
I knew that.
I'll just take this.
Oh, but, duh, duh, blind, but since it's a Chrono-Kal,
it's something.
Kick, jab, back into your normal position.
Throw your junk away, since you're no longer a contender.
Fear, Bakshi are much more powerful than Bohrok-Kal.
Jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab, jab.
Oh, you okay?
I'm having a pool, Makuta.
Vacuum power.
Straight jab.
Uh, I'm gonna get ya.
I'm standing so high.
More powerful than that.
When I talk to you, you may do that with other people, but not with Lay-Bok-Kal.
I can't even do that with other people, but not with Lay-Bok-Kal.
Lay-Bok-Kal.
Go on, Lay-Bok.
Scared?
A good Bohrok, not a bad Bohrok.
You can't even do that with Tanak and Gurak.
Galak.
When you bump into a Bohrok, you can't get up.
The Bohrok is supposed to do this.
So this is a Bohrok, Destroyer of the Head of Makuta's Head Papa.
This is my last Giddy Prod-ed.
With me if I'm gonna fail.
Whoa.
I didn't die.
Cool.
Telekinesis.
Gra-te, gravity telekinesis.
Boreist.
I'm supposed to do that.
No, you talk and I cannot fail.
I can't.
I failed.
Shoot him.
I finally got to.
Kick.
Ow.
Ow, my nose.
Oh, don't start this again.
Yeah, get off.
The grab is starting to wear off.
He's Barack Obama.
I hate Mubacca.
We're gonna hate me.
Vacuum blast.
Nuclear implosion.
Not exist, Makoto.
It's a virtual mishap.
Don't touch it, Farai.
You'll get sucked into it forever.
Don't touch anybody's car in reality.
Eerie.
I failed.
Nitrogen fixation fusion.
You failed.
The two last Barack calls.
Your base up thing like this.
Put your spanner on.
Okay.
Then you put this right here.
Put all your karma in here.
And you put it like that.
I was one of the first Barack,
I was the first Barack call to be found.
Cool.
You're like the third.
You're the one who thought later about.
Should I use my.
Fools.
Well, guess what?
I sent out Barack so he can drain your electricity.
And Gura so she can separate what you magnetize.
Makoto, you've got a brain, but it's not very big.
Haven't you noticed that I only have the power
of electricity, I also have the power of fire.
Because fire pertains to electricity.
Use forceful magnetism.
Use the magnetism and put a negative charge on his chest
and put a positive charge on the ground,
because I know all about magnetism.
I'm the Barack of electricity.
Magnetism and shields at it drain your energy.
Or to resist the power of the magnetism.
But it wasn't.
Opposite of stuck together.
Now, magnetism is the same thing.
Making things fly apart is magnetism.
You got to put it.
You got to put like, if you wanted Makoto,
if you wanted his claws to fly apart, you got to put the.
you'd have to make them both positive charges like charges repel and different
charges go together see cool different charges switch them that means that this
one needs to be on this side now they're attracted each side change them all the
the same charge yes I'm gonna do it we're gonna change these in negative
negative see now those can't touch each other but it was my thing you shouldn't
have put that one in last hmm or you can maybe you could trick this is my second
favorite
okay I treated it like a crown um you know water I'm gonna go do it
I gotta do something get this big wall energetic thunder sliding bolt to
Makita's head this is how you charge yourself up yeah I'm tapping into the
power of electricity the power of whatever I have for oxy two different
charges charge them really hard with it
okay now hey go tell me you heard my head shaking what
I'll take that I'm taking it look who does jump in the files yeah Makita we are
gonna finish you off sissy I'll show you the power of the Baraka it's locked in Makita this is the
end prepare yourself Makita slow some three of the Baraka she has magnetism um sonic stuff
something powerful for hidden I'm gonna do it
watch this I have a chronic what if I go like this hard to play hey cool my arm's
coming loose here's my feet Mega R I'm too powerful but I can fight can I heal
you you only have one eye so I can keep control of you ooh you're asking for we are the most
powerful Bionicle so far don't hurt her you can roll into a ball to protect yourself
or something some kind of shape that's your protective
you melt you melt you it's welded to your back well into your back you like
cheese I can't take any of this even though I'm a Baraka you said my energy is
pretty low that was mine my shoulders too heavy for my leg shall we pull our
energy into it our last attack or not I think knock them out just to give you
energy well I feel better now I feel better now I feel better now I feel better
way too soon reality fail it's the Toa nooboka ita hey we're going exact event
that means we can't move around and some head this is my beam cannon my head comes
off easily though gonna fight right hey it's easy to pick there are new joggers
you're not shooting for the Toa in a modification because the new joggers are going what was that um now I have an opportunity
Too bad we can't surf on this, but it's a great weapon.
It's hard to battle.
I know, but we don't have to hit him.
We can just use beam attacks.
Magician Strike!
Hey, he was easy to knock down.
Get them, Roxy!
I like doing accurate.
Too bad you lost your Krana to Tanaka.
Don't remind me of that.
Then I guess it wasn't true that you're in the Krana.
Otherwise, Tanaka would have taken you.
I don't need that fool anyway.
Anyway, I'm much more stronger with them.
I thought I needed them last year.
Beer!
You want some power?
You can drain energy.
It's not an antenna, it's an antenna.
That's Vorok's power.
Thanks, Tanaka.
Vorok, attack her! Use your anger!
Hey, did you know when we change masks, we get the personality of the antenna that it came from?
Have you ever had a mask that...
Brain cramp.
I never thought of that.
I did.
I've heard that there are some legendary masks that have this little...
Stick intent instead of pegs that stay on your mouse.
Yeah, I heard that too.
Like the Kanoe Kraken!
What?
The mask of shadow.
And the mask of light.
You're a-
Light, light, light.
Dirk, Dirk.
Come on, sing with me.
Dirk.
Dirk, Dirk.
Dirk, Dirk, Dirk.
Dirk Dirk.
Dirk, Dirk.
I can do better.
I can do anything better than you.
And you can't.
If I can.
No, you can't.
Yes I can! Yes I can!
This is not supposed to be fun!
You're the last one!
Can you kick? No.
Since I'm like a hockey spirit, I can kick really-
My foot keeps getting caught behind his neck.
Why don't you use Gally's hook, um, axes to use a water attack?
Weird, my mask looks like pudding.
Does my mask look like pudding?
Yeah.
You gonna fight?
Beer.
Beer cannon.
No.
There's a soda cannon there.
Shake-a, shake-a, shake-a, shake-a.
Here, look.
It appears in the-
Shake-a, shake-a, shake-a, shake-a, shake-a, shake-a.
You try.
Right in the spirit of soda.
Beer somewhere?
Did you find my gear?
Sure.
It flew around.
I can't-
You're welcome.
Why aren't you fighting?
I'm getting out of that jungle, Jesus.
Ugh.
I'm talking about having a stick in my leg, cause I do.
Oh my gosh, look what you did to me.
Weird what?
I'm going to make you confused.
Haha, you should see yourself.
I am going to kick you.
That kind of hurts, you know.
That's not your final attack.
That was weak.
Energy.
It's now.
Farag, defend yourselves.
Sucker bomb.
You cannot defeat us this time, practicing my voice.
That's how I used to go like this.
That's how I used to talk.
You're not gonna eat my hair this time, either.
We battled with you.
We are still picking hair out of our teeth.
Extra hairspray.
Yeah.
It's gonna be harder than before.
Yeah, I bet you were growing your hair back.
I took my hands out so you wouldn't snag them off and rip my ears.
Don't.
You're a mack.
That's ham backwards.
And you're a hot dog.
You should have wore boots.
I'm not wearing any shoes.
Uh, don't.
Of course she's the master of ninja moves in the Super Family.
Shinbag.
I have failed.
Ah, new Jabba.
Watch.
You may have gotten a getup, but you haven't won't get me.
I'm much more trained in, um, eye, hand, hand-eye coordination.
Hand and claw.
I mean, claw and eye.
Like this bell?
Do you see the shine in the bell?
Your hand looks weird.
Stacy!
Something bit it so mean.
You can't leave.
Reject her.
Reject that stupid, newie Jabba.
It can't do anything.
Makoto, you should have gotten rid of them in the first place.
They can't attack right.
Good idea.
We'll take them.
Well, newie Jabba, you're free to go.
My legs are flexible.
That did not sound right.
See?
My leg is too flexible.
You cannot take those masks.
They're too well guarded.
Mm-hmm.
Those masks are too well guarded for you to get.
Those newie Jabba should stay here and fight.
You're going to have to heal us before we battle Dr. Shrew.
Makoto, I'm any day.
Yes?
What is it?
You need to, like, heal us before you hit my spikes anyway.
And it's already not on your speech.
Get her, Rock Sheep.
Here?
Here.
And you bit the clip out.
Don't take my pretzels.
I mean, that's what baby Ella called these things.
Um, she took one off and then she put it on her nose and then she twisted her head.
Who?
Baby Ella.
That's why.
She was like, hey, you haven't been in action for long.
That was another time.
Yeah.
And, um.
Left, left, left, left, here.
Yeah.
And also, um, she went like, um, stale.
Stale weapon.
Ah!
Yup.
Stale weapon.
With the enemy.
Get her!
And you know what else?
Listen to my, listen to my knee crack.
Destroy her.
Release from the robot.
Do you like being attacked?
No.
It's actually.
Go into defensive mode.
And detach from the robot.
Get her!
Let go of my hair.
I won't let go of your hair.
That's a shot, you know.
Shots do not affect, um, adults in the rock.
Just use your poison instead of shots.
You are the rock.
You have poison.
Aren't you?
We finally woke up.
Cause you're dead.
I.
Oh.
Oh no.
Not music again.
Barag, please do not try to kill me.
I'm gonna get on her side.
I'm gonna need backup.
The lights.
Every little bit of your weakness is.
Super family.
The most powerful one in the super family is coming.
Doctor senior.
The one and only.
Welcome.
We are hopeful that you have watched this movie so long.
You have watched about 11 hours straight of this movie.
We hope.
Well, you are probably tormented right now, but, um.
It is apparent that, um, the, the subtitle you have just seen just suggests, just suggested
that we have, um, a very violent battle coming up.
Because if Doctor Senior has a whole part dedicated to him, you know that this is gonna
be big.
Actually, this is two parts.
So.
Children.
We please ask you to act.
Yes.
That you are doing this.
Because this might, you, Doctor Senior might be fighting for your lives here.
Um.
But, always remember that you must be careful.
Do not go try this on any of your friends, or anybody.
I'm serious about this.
We ask all children under the age of six to leave now because of graphic violence.
If, like, the parents.
Or the older sister or brother want to watch, then you could possibly, um, quickly just
go, get them to go into another room for a little bit, or just watch TV in another room.
Yes.
Um.
This will be a very violent part of the battle, as I mentioned before, so.
Your discretion is advised.
Some of your favorite bad characters might get hurt.
Um.
And there is a lot bodily violence.
That is all I have to say.
Amanda, do you have any further announcements?
Yeah.
There will not be what you expected, because you might expect something not so violent.
Because it's probably really going to be violent.
And there's just one other thing that there probably won't be any blood, so I don't know
if you're, like.
Five, four, three, two, one-year-old, probably not one, two, three-year-old, or four, five-year-old.
Um.
If they're mature enough, um, then maybe they could come, but I doubt it.
And just in case you shouldn't bring any violent enders.
Well, actually.
Okay.
These are our final announcements.
Now, please enjoy the rest of the feature.
You will enjoy from.
You will enjoy about one hour and ten minutes left in the movie.
So, please be patient.
Just quiet.
Dad, when are we going to battle?
I don't know.
It's been a while.
Dada da da.
Dada da da da.
Your footsteps.
McKinney!
What are you doing here?
I thought you were knocked out.
I wasn't.
I retreated.
And now I've finally waited.
I want to battle Dr. Smule.
Can't you see I'm busy preparing?
No, Makuta.
I think you are ready.
We have every one of your minions out.
Let me tell you something.
For a while, you snuck inside our
AAC and blew it up.
And now, all that will be
avenged.
We know you must be something, Makuta.
Other than some dumb
megalomaniac.
Because
you drove our minds to vengeance.
And we are peaceful.
And we are peaceful with vengeance.
It's a crime.
And it must be paid back.
Well, if you would have just let me alone,
I would have...
You would have...
But we could not live with the fact that you were destroying the universe.
I am not destroying the universe.
I am just plowing it over.
For my...
It all stops now.
You've been extremely, extremely
annoying.
We've challenged you
five times.
Yeah, we've challenged you.
At least five times already.
Well, it would make six now.
I didn't include
now, Makuta.
You don't even sound like a Matoran.
I am Takawa.
The Chronicle.
Oh, that's very, very interesting.
But I have much, much more, Makuta.
You don't get it.
I discovered something, Makuta.
Anyone
can find their true destiny.
No, they can't. Matoran have no destiny.
They only have the destiny
to be protected by ones more superior
than them. You don't get it, Makuta.
We Matoran
are strong, and in our hearts
we believe. Look at your body.
I mean, you don't have legs,
you have feet instead of legs.
Your arms are like the mask
that will be your doom.
You might want to refer it to the Mask of Doom.
It's the Mask of Destiny.
It's true name is
the Kanoe Evoki.
The Mask?
The Kanoe Evoki has the ability
to freeze an opponent
in the Columns of Light.
Make an opponent feel
feelings of peace.
That is why none of you
are feeling it.
You tell us.
I did not want to hear this.
What can you do with that Mask of Lust?
You're just a Matoran.
There are many things, Makuta.
And the first of them
is your demise.
Dwarri, Dwarri, Dwarri, Dwarri.
There is an illusion.
Light will
no matter how deep
the darkness, a light
shines within!
I am Entakenuva,
Toa of Light.
I don't get it.
What happened to the Matoran I was looking at
a few seconds earlier?
Makuta never understood
anybody without
discovering their personality first.
Wait a minute.
I hear more footsteps.
You're tiny compared to him.
Actually, he's a little larger
than he should be.
Makuta,
it is time.
Dr. Senor.
Take a good look around this world,
Makuta.
I have a feeling that they are tricking us somehow.
Is this some kind of illusion?
Some way to trick
the Master of Shadows?
It is a way that will show
who is the dominant one
of the family, Makuta.
You mean...
Yes, we are battling.
Prepare yourself, Makuta.
This will be the end for you.
Are you ready, Makuta?
Who's first?
Dwarri, Bwaka, Kanra, Vinkai,
and both Nuna and Rama.
Interesting. All right, Lin.
Let's go.
So, are we ready?
Yes.
Now, prepare yourself, Makuta.
Think about what you already did.
You're going to give up the battle.
Oh, they will win. I'm sure of it.
Sure of losing?
Actually, this is my weakest victory.
I don't mean to do that.
Target!
We just did.
Dr. Senor, do you want to hold back?
No, I'll help you out.
Even though I don't need some,
it's good to have somebody with me.
Ready.
I wonder, Makuta, why you were so weak.
You talk with crackly voices.
Ah!
Well, once you defeat them,
you will never find me.
You don't have a body, do you?
Not that wimpy thing.
Okay, then send it out.
Then we'll tear it to shreds.
Like a napkin.
So, where's that wimpy body I was talking about?
You've transformed!
That is right.
I'm in time for you to run along now,
and let me conquer the world.
You can't possibly defeat me
and my Rahkshi.
Nobody has been able to knock the Rahkshi out.
And they're at full health
right now, aren't they?
Yes, Dad. We are still at full health.
You're just trying to taunt us.
I know this.
Oh, is that true?
I'll take you down.
Wait, Dr. Senor. I'll take care of the Barag.
You stand by.
Rahkshi, step back a little.
I'll take care of the Barag all by myself.
Is that true?
Oh, but too bad you won't be able to get my weak spot anyway.
Because I'm protecting it.
You're extremely powerful.
But you must get used to mine once you get used to mine.
I can. I'm not something as large as you.
Slash.
Blade, extend.
Dad, this one hurts.
You'll never take my mask off.
Only when my head comes off.
Slash. Slash.
Be hard.
That one hurt.
I hate this fool Takanuva.
You're gonna hate me even more, Makuta.
Because you know what?
Dr. Senor is waiting in your powerup for a hyper supernova beam.
To finish you off for the final time.
Twins.
I'm about to give you a slash that you'll never forget.
Shall I get out my Asanui?
Asanui?
Yes.
This fool Takanuva keeps getting me things.
I'm gonna take you down.
I don't get in the Exo Tower.
Huh?
I'm the only one that doesn't belong in the Exo Tower.
I have the Asanui.
Oh, so that is true.
But what can you do with that?
Race around and, um,
just be a coward?
No.
I can use one of my most powerful attacks with it.
Oh, is that so?
Oh, go on.
Show it to us then.
I will once I'm in.
I meant for that to be something annoying to you.
Well, it wasn't.
Too bad, Makuta.
You're losing all your...
what you used to be.
Who dares to challenge me?
You're gonna have to get off of us.
So you wanna fight, huh?
You're going to be defeated.
Why?
You cannot possibly defeat us.
I failed.
Attack.
Yes.
Let me try.
You're blind.
You don't fight good.
You're asking for it, Makuta.
Dr. Snior, power up for Hyper Supernova Beam.
Yes, Kakanuba.
So, Makuta.
You have grown more powerful since I last saw you.
I have never seen you.
Well, maybe you have.
I've been in your dreams for years.
Yes, I have.
I've never seen it totally.
Well, what about Kopaka?
She's too dark to be.
So, Makuta, let's battle.
First move.
She got dripping off my mask. That is power.
And you would never understand it, Makuta.
Well, I'll bridge over your life.
Just give me a second.
It's all over, Dr. Sn...
Takanuva.
Prepare to be destroyed.
The time has come.
The time when the Super Family finally defeats you.
Come destroy me,
for I am nothing.
That is true.
But so many years in darkness
must have made you blind.
I remember back in the days of the Power Team
when the most violent and evil attack
of that time
the Portal of Chaos
and the evil brother used it.
I have grown so powerful
over the years that
I feel I now have the ability
to harness that energy
when I discovered that Hyper Supernova Beam
is powerful enough to create that attack
on its own.
That means that we now have the ability
to imprison you forever, Makuta.
Let me tell you a saying that a wise man
once said.
Men wear masks upon which they carve portraits
of what they want to be
like
or think they ought to be.
Opportunity, like fortune,
does not change a man.
It unmasks him.
What lies under the mask may surprise you
as it often surprised the person,
but it was always there.
Let's see what you
truly look like.
So much smoke.
You found my true form.
I will make you strong enough.
I am the void
of Makuta. Challenge me.
Yes, Makuta.
This will be the
deciding moment
in our final battle.
Why don't you stare
onto us? I do not bear it.
You are to fight
the Rahkshi first.
Oh, so are we.
Right then, we're going to
strip them of their power.
Oh, is that so?
So what do you think you can do
with that little stack of light and mask of light
and Doctor Senora's power?
Well,
it's pretty much evil
when it's pretty much
obvious what we're going to do.
So,
you give in to my
power already?
No, I don't, Makuta.
All right.
Let us battle.
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun.
Tura!
Challenge the void.
I feel you. Nothing.
It's time to end this
Takanuva. I agree.
I'll use the power of the Vahid to call
on all the power
good has and had,
including God's
and his son's power.
I'll call on all the
final beams and spirits
of the Super Family.
Combine your collected power
with mine, and I'll fire it off
with the Hyper Supernova Beam.
...of me strength.
It is impossible to defeat
the spirit of destruction.
I know that, Makuta,
but you can never dream of this energy,
for it is
everyone's power.
You do not seem to get it,
Toa of Light.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Poor Doctor Senor.
Super Chaotic
Black Hole Beam of Destruction!
Combined
with all good's
power. Passed.
Doctor Senor, the end.
It's what you think.
Rise, Makuta.